[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
todos acá saben que la luna vive un
conejo no
las aves
en la luna viene un conejo
a mí me lo contó el millón
un chico que entonces tenía 10 años y
vivía noche en la huasteca potosina en
méxico
emilio
a emilio se lo contó su papá
al papá de mi papá
el papá de papá de emilio su papá
parece que una vez un señor estaba
trabajando en su siembra estaba
cosechando y se encontró con un conejo
que le estaba comiendo los frijoles
entonces el hombre va a buscar un arma
para matarlo
pero cuando llegó el conejo le hablo
te pidió que no lo mates
y le contó que iba a ver una gran
inundación
y el señor de egreso
construcción barco se subieron y empezó
a llover y llovió horas días años y el
agua subió y el barco subió y quedó
pegadito a la luna
y el conejo salto
en la luna vive un conejo
pasaron los años el agua bajo el señor
volvió a su casa y se comió un pescado
frito
los chicos no mienten
como conocí yo
a emilio en la huasteca potosina méxico
en el año 2011 mi compañero sayo me
propuso que hagamos un viaje juntos por
toda américa latina un viajecito
los dos él era carpintero comunicador
social yo maestra de parvulario los dos
éramos
militantes sociales y vivíamos en una
gran ciudad en rosario en argentina
a mí la idea me entusiasmo tenía ganas
de conocer experiencias que nos ayuden a
formarnos para aprender a vivir y
construir colectivamente
entonces agarramos un carro armamos una
casita
y buscamos un pretexto algo que nos
ayuda a encontrarnos con los pueblos
y se nos ocurrió el cielo
y salimos
los llenamos de libros astronómicos los
llenamos de dispositivos para enseñar
atractivamente astronomía y los llenamos
de telescopios
y no hacía mucho tiempo que estábamos de
viaje unos meses cuando llegamos al
norte de chile
al desierto a un vasito en el medio del
desierto donde zona minera
y ahí nos encontramos con una comunidad
de 25 familias atacameñas
ellos administraban colectivamente un
pucará una escuela y un comedor en ese
comedor había una señora una cocinera
muy amable muy simpática y que hacía la
mejor torta veta ramo de remolacha
durante el día hacíamos los talleres
experimentales en la escuela con los
cinco alumnos que tenían la escuela
y en la noche ahí al costado
aprovechamos esos cielos diáfanos del
desierto y sacábamos los telescopios y
hacíamos observaciones y la gente venía
a mirar y a charlar ya la última noche
nosotros estábamos guardando todas las
cosas preparando el carro para salir al
día siguiente cuando vemos que se acerca
la cocinera venía tan ponchadas con el
sobrino
viene y nos cuenta que cuando ella era
chica solía mirar el cielo con su papá
siempre sentados en el mismo tronco y su
papá le llenaba ese cielo de las
historias más fabulosas
ese era el mejor recuerdo que tenía su
infancia
y el mejor recuerdo de su papá y
nosotros estábamos mirando a saturno
entonces la mujer
pego el ojo y miro
y después nos dijo
me puedo morir tranquila volvió a ser
niña
al día siguiente ya estábamos en ruta
con sal si no podíamos parar de pensar
era una escena muy sencilla la que
habíamos visto pero otra profunda
humanidad ya nosotros nos caló hondo
nos dimos cuenta que teníamos que dejar
un poquito de lado está astronomía
accidental y empezar a escuchar más lo
que la gente tiene para decir sobre ese
cielo
y con esta idea
sigamos acá a bolivia
primero acá la paz donde trabajamos en
escuelas comedores orfanatos y acá
pasamos a tocan ya conocimos en los
afrobolivianos
y de tocar jazz seguimos a patacamaya
él patacamaya estábamos en una escuela
industrial y una noche la directora
cristina nos hace una invitación
nos propone que nos vayamos de noche con
un cura en un sip a un pueblo en la
montaña
quería que conozcamos a los maestros
caminantes
los maestros caminantes
son estos maestros que caminan horas y
días entre las montañas para llegar a
enseñar a aquellas personas que quieren
aprender a leer escribir
era muy interesante fuimos y estos
maestros la preguntaron y ustedes qué
hacen y nosotros enseñamos sobre el
cielo
y ahí nos enseñaron
nos contaron que leyendo el brillo de un
grupo de estrellas podían saber cuál era
la mejor noche para confeccionar el
sueño
y como gesto hay una explicación
científica estas son las pléyades es un
grupo abierto o un cúmulo abierto de
estrellas ellas cuando la noche tiene
menos contaminación menos humedad es más
seca el brillo de las estrellas es más
nítido entonces ellas sabían cuándo iba
a ser la noche de helada seca entonces
ponían las telas sobre sobre el piso
ponían las papas y las dejaban ahí y a
la noche al día siguiente a la mañana la
junta van las molían y podían almacenar
comida
para nosotros fue fascinante
porque a lo largo y ancho de este
planeta la humanidad las mujeres y los
hombres miramos el cielo
lo estudiamos y observamos lo valoramos
y lo domesticados para cosas como estas
tener alimentos
y también pero organizarnos socialmente
de ahí con esta historia queremos
aprender más de astronomía andina
y nos fuimos a conocer
a un gran astrónomo un gran arqueos
programa que usted tienen acá que se
llama manuel de la torre que tiene su
observatorio en el lago titicaca
y cuando le comentamos manuel nos contó
más historias y nos dijo que desde
siempre
los andinos podían encontrar
constelaciones en las zonas oscuras de
la vía láctea cuando nosotros vemos la
vía láctea esta franja en el cielo lo
que estamos viendo es el centro de la
galaxia de nuestra galaxia porque
estamos una orillita no más cuando
nosotros miramos toda esa luz miramos el
centro de la galaxia pero hay algunas
zonas oscuras donde nos permiten no se
permite el paso de luz y en esas zonas
los incas encontraron animales
cuentan que hay vive una llama con su
cría y que hay una época en el año en
que esta llama con su cría están sobre
el horizonte bebiendo el agua de los
ríos
y cuidando de que no se desborde y que
esto coincide justamente con la época de
sequía
tiempo después la familia 3 para el
cielo y se pone en el cenit y empieza a
llover empiezan las épocas de lluvia
porque estará haciendo pis
con todas estas historias nosotros
decirlo se nos iba acordando engordaba
y nos replanteamos nuestro nuestro
proyecto nuestro viaje que somos
maestros astrónomos viajeros pues no
seamos puentes llevemos estas historias
de una orilla a la otra pero también se
nos ocurrió
ser una familia y ahí me pasa se puso
gorda
muy gorda y me empezó a evitar una niña
que después llamamos negra
y así con esa panza después de recorrer
llegamos a méxico primero la panza
después nosotros
y el carro también por suerte llegado
después de que perdió una rueda le
cambiamos el motor dormido cantidad de
noches y terminó ahí de macetero en un
campo
con esto llegamos ahí queríamos ir a
conocer el sur de méxico la zona de
chiapas zonas zapatistas y fuimos a una
comunidad que se llama acteal entonces
las montañas selváticas
con esta intención de repensar nuestro
rol
propusimos hacer primero
un trabajo de observación
así que a los chicos les dimos una
cámara de fotos y cada uno tomaba una
foto sobre lo que cotidianamente veía
pero con mayor profundidad para después
socializar lo
así aprendimos de plantas
animales de insectos de siembra y
nosotros estábamos chochos teníamos un
montón de cosas para contar y todo esto
que escuchábamos lo guardábamos y
entonces hablamos con marcos con el
maestro y le compartíamos esta felicidad
por todo lo que estábamos conociendo
marcos era el único maestro bilingüe que
hablaba esos citi que nos podía hacer de
traductor para que nos podamos comunicar
y él también estaba muy orgulloso de su
comunidad dice y de sus alumnos
pero le pasaba algo a marcos tenía una
profunda contradicción
porque tenía que enseñar contenidos de
manuales que nada tenían que ver con la
realidad que vivían tenía que hablar de
aviones de semáforos de la ciudad
y al mismo tiempo veía como todos estos
conocimientos mayas ancestrales
iban desapareciendo fueron ninguneados
todas estas particularidades culturales
quedaban asimiladas a una única cultura
globalizadora
y esta era terrible
nos preguntábamos con marcos
[Música]
qué
y porque deciden lo que tenemos que
saber
y entonces ahí nos propusimos una nueva
tarea
además de los talleres
estos marcos la comunidad de esos
alumnos
a partir de ahí nos propusimos tres
cosas indagar registrar y difundir así
que estaríamos por todos lados hacer
entrevistas y los chicos también
abuela porque cuando te miras la luna te
pones una telita que tiene unos hilos
ahí
y mi hijito para poder saber 1 del 12
del 13 de luna
el maíz septiembre la luna llena para
que pueda crecer más alto
a mí me contó mi mamá que cuando hay
eclipse las embarazadas no tienen que
salir sino después beben le puede faltar
un pedacito
nos llenábamos de historias nosotros
escribíamos registrábamos escuchábamos y
nos comprometíamos a poder difundirlo
como ahora que se los estoy contando
y en eso
negra crecía y se hacía amigos muchos
amigos hizo y la compartíamos y para
nosotros era la mejor forma de vivir
como familia
y creció
y tuvo una hermana coral que nació en
brasil
y así seguimos y volvimos a casa
y este viaje que iba a ser una vueltita
para mí no hay acá la tina de un año
terminaron siendo cinco años
y dedos que salimos terminamos volviendo
negra coral y una perla para whatsapp
y volvimos y la gente nos pregunta y qué
tal el viaje
estuvo bueno
si estos buenos aprendimos un montón
aprendimos de todas las cosmovisiones
locales nos enseñaron compartimos
compartimos familia hicimos amigos
muchos amigos tenemos gente en todos
lados
tuvimos la oportunidad
de vivir una vida una experiencia
maravillosa
y todo por mirar el cielo
el cielo es uno de los únicos lugares
que nos quedan
que no tiene fronteras
que no tiene dueños que es gratis que
está ahí
así que existir en la suerte de ir a la
interperie de encontrarse con el cielo
que sea de noche
y están con alguien para compartirlo y
decirlo está abiertos y si hay una luna
y si esa luna está grande y está llena
acuérdense que hay un conejo
aunque tal como me enseñaron en
guatemala
o un dragón
un hombre cangrejo como me dijeron en el
salvador
o lo que ustedes tengan ganas
gracias
[Aplausos]